one of the things that I'm fascinated by
is humans capacity I think humans are
bad at scale this is where media and
information and the way the world Works
fascinates me humans are stunningly
amazing of the 8 billion people that
roam this Earth it is stunning how many
are remarkable to at least neutral yet
we are infatuated with paying attention
to the one percent of the one percent of
the one percent that are not yeah
the fuel of my ambition is like this
beautiful mix of gratitude and even like
micro guilt it comes from such a place
of like I'm so happy and like so many
people aren't very inspired on a daily
basis while I'm doing my thing to figure
out ways to say something and change the
perspective in some way that might help
someone start to achieve more happiness
the other big Revelation for me as I go
through my journey is how many people's
ambition is completely fueled by
insecurity and I actually think that's a
problem it's not sustainable when you're
able to use that to amass dollars money
doesn't change you money exposes you so
if you're at a bad place and you like
wanted to prove everyone wrong and then
you got the money then you're going to
spend that money on dumb what makes
you happy leaving an impact on the world
makes me very happy I live a life where
more than a thousand people a day reach
out to me and say thank you for
something they didn't buy for me or I
sold them and that feels incredible I
love spending time with friends and
family really love garage sailing how
excited I am that it's like early March
because I'm like a couple more weeks
there was a time and place where my
content was like hey I worked for 12
years in my dad's liquor store I never
made a lot of money but I lived within
my means so I was able to have some
savings Twitter and Facebook and Tumblr
came along and I invested that money
into it you can too and then I started
getting emails like I don't twenty five
thousand dollars to invest in a startup
and I started getting enough of that
that I was like good fine I'll just go
further back in my journey and I'll show
you what I did when I had zero dollars
and zero cents I woke up at six o'clock
in the morning on a Saturday and went
garage sailing especially when eBay
first came out no different than the way
I talk about social media creative which
is like when there's a new platform that
has enough attention on it there's not
enough content for it so if you go there
heavily and aggressively and you post
organically you're going to get a lot
more organic reach for no cost and
that's a land grab of attention and
because social is where so much of
society is playing out this is very
important well the same thing happened
with internet 1.0 so few people knew
what was going on on eBay there was more
people searching for stuff to buy
because it was the first time collectors
in the late 90s could find Pez
dispensers or video games or comic books
not going to a Big Show or a store there
wasn't as many people listing them so
everything was super valuable like you
could make a thousand dollars garage
selling with 80 bucks every single
Saturday if you were willing to put in
the work obviously that market evolved
but it's still very true I still believe
that the biggest opportunity for
somebody who has five hundred dollars is
to buy and sell things in the Arbitrage
of the way Society Works between
Poshmark thrift store and Craigslist at
a garage sale and eBay and so I got
motivated to make that content I think
that's a really important thing uh to
kind of uh tailor your content basically
to popular culture I think it's a
massive misstep of most people that
they're not taking advantage of the
emotion behind popular culture and
integrating it look at how I popped Wine
Library TV is how I hit the scene 17
years ago I did a wine show on YouTube
the day YouTube basically came out it
worked because while I was doing the
wine tasting I was referencing what was
happening in the world people are not
winning on relevance people trying to
sell instead of build emotion
popular culture is one of the pillars of
our emotion human truths and popular
culture
it's only hard mentally you just haven't
decided that's the most important thing
your business does it is the most
important thing it is of course creating
demand and consideration for your
business
is always the most important thing if
you were able to grow top line revenue
and perpetuity you always have the
ability to fix Ops and costs it's
actually very easy if you told me
everybody here does from 1 million to
100 million in Revenue it's super easy
they're just taking too much money home
to buy things the most important thing
might be to sell your business and go
sailing it might be
but if we're talking next level like
you're in business and you're about that
life well I would argue there's nothing
one can tell me here that is going to
get me more excited than having them
completely commit to creating demand
what are some of the payroll decisions
trying to make no profit for as long as
possible so Vayner started no nine first
two years AJ really ran and I still had
to run the business plus I wrote crush
it and the whole time we poured all the
money back into business the pivotal
decision was feeding the business not my
ego or my bank account or my devices
thank you
foreign